sing one excuse that these girls could
have and I'm certainly not you know I
don't don't know which side of this I've
fallen right now but the dating game has
changed because of internet dating so
dramatically in my opinion that men have
taken the control of like they just
expect sex from the jump so now if
you're a woman who's holding out it's a
lot harder to keep a man interested when
the the power is now more with the men
than it's ever been and the expectation
of sex is more higher than it's ever
been so for a woman to to keep a man
interested long enough to know if he's
going to be a serious Contender you
kinda are
not force but more inclined to give them
that because you don't want him to go
along to the next girl because he's
going to get it there anyway he wants it
I think that's a fair argument for the
small percentage of men that are getting
screwed by multiple girls but I think
for most cases I think in most cases The
Leverage is actually with the women
because most men aren't getting laid